at the time the novel was published a
little over seven years ago 2007 I had
finished reading a book aloud to my five
and seven year old boys and I was
looking for another and I literally
googled read aloud books six-year-old
boys up pops a new york times review
fresh off of the times in the past days
of Adam Rex's book the true meaning of
smack day and Adam is a kids book
illustrator of some renown with many
books published but this was his first
novel ordered it read it and as I've
said now 22 others I tucked the boys in
after two chapters on a Friday night and
then cheated on them and stayed up till
two in the morning because I had to know
what happened next I fell in love with
the characters in the tone and Suzanne
maybe you can pick it up from there what
I understand that that the author was
involved with you guys in terms of
adapting it and and I guess what was the
process like of just getting this off
the ground at the early stages well we
took a little bit of a leap from the
book in that you know Tim really wanted
to make it a global story and and in the
book kind of covered the states and we
wanted to make it about about the whole
world so we left from there and then
Adam tends to be a tiny bit darker in a
little more cynical than we wanted to go
so even though there's so many things in
the book that are still in the film like
literally verbatim things that were in
the book so that's kind of what we did
with it now last year before mr. Peabody
& Sherman there was a short that was
shown called almost home and I just
wonder what the relationship is between
that and this if there is one I just
thought it was kind of neat um you know
we live in an environment today when
having an original movie not based on a
huge selling book or existing franchiser
a superhero is frankly a scary
proposition and these movies animated
movies are not inexpensive films and so
the thought how do you introduce
characters to the crazy world of these
aliens called the booth we got very
excited about the idea of let's let's do
a short let's do it long enough out from
the movie that we can have fun
introducing the tone of the characters
and so the short kind of Chronicles
captain smek and the moves many attempts
to find a home world being pursued by
the
enemy the gorg and so as well as every
other sort of living creature in the
universe the boof just have a very hard
time of it so it was a really fun
outrageous way to introduce audiences to
a good section of the film another thing
I'm sure a lot of people are wondering
is how you came to these voice actors in
light of the fact that I think with the
exception of Steve Martin for a day on
the Prince of Egypt none of them had
done animation animated movies voice
work previously Rihanna Jim Parsons
there it seems now like oh of course you
would have to go for them but at the
time what was the process that led you
to them well I think I think Tim always
felt like Jim Parsons was the guy for
the alien and and you know the minute
you hear him there's just you realize
there's just no one else that could do
that there's music to his voice and when
you close your eyes as we do an
animation if you if you watch some of
these actors you're going to fall in
love with them their charisma their
power but without naming any names in
particular some actors have a voice like
this and its really really intense and
you fall in love with him but you would
never want to animate that ah Jim does
not have that problem and and and taught
well we'll pick up with Rihanna in this
way if we can which is that Suzanne you
you've obviously got a rich background
in animation but also in music and so I
just have to ask was it always was a
thought it would be nice to cast someone
who is also going to be able to
contribute a lot of music to the film as
was the case with Rihanna did it was
that just a perk of of the way it worked
out I think it was just like the whole
thing is kind of magical I have to say
the way everything came together and you
know we had this girl of color that we
you know we decided came from the
islands and then Rihanna's name came up
and the music sort of evolved in a
certain kind of way and everything was
just just sort of fell together I you
know I was a folk singer I didn't you
know have any any ideas about what
exactly this is going to be but but but
Suzanne undersell yourself there I I'm
just a folk singer says the touring
musician with multiple albums of the
fact that Susan had that insight into
singer-songwriters and had a pretty
sophisticated understanding both on the
creative side and Frank
like the byzantine business world she
really was the champion and helped
Corral a huge number of songs flowed
through Suzanne's hands 40 50 song that
we really seriously considered but
listen it was a learning experience for
everybody where some of these rihanna
songs just forgive my ignorance but were
they were they previously out there some
of them written for the film or I just
think the music is such a great part of
this movie and it really kind of keeps
the energy level up more than in some
movies and all of that so well you know
I even before Rihanna was involved we
were exploring a more sophisticated use
of pop tunes at the same time I can't
stand needle drop where things come to a
shattering halt for a song I did feel
that the music of 12 year old girl
listens to is pop music and it felt very
odd to me to have a ad piece orchestra
playing in back of this young girls
journey and so from the start we were
thinking of it when Rihanna got involved
and her her team Stargate miquelon tour
songwriter producers we realized we
really had a significant opportunity to
up it from existing tunes to you know
basically all of them except for one
hour original written for the movie so
it really is sort of a musical in which
the characters don't open their mouths
and sing but every word and every note
was written by people who watch the
movie and responded to it Wow well I
gotta ask a geeky question which is that
I understand this is the second time
that only the second time the dreamers
animation has employed this platform
Apollo other time I think was how to
train a dragon 2 what does that actually
mean for you guys when you're making the
movie what is this and look Nabal you to
do that wasn't necessarily possible as
well before well on the on the creative
front these are new tools that allow an
animator too much more intuitively grab
what they want move it spin the
character around and you know animation
is still to me the strangest of art
forms and I started as an animator doing
captain crunch commercials back in
Chicago um what I love about animation
is whether you're a singer or a dance or
a painter you are in immediate contact
with your art animators work in still
frames but their art is motion so the
quickest you can go from a pose a PO
opposed and then seen it move the more
you can get your hands on the actual art
which is acting and emotional
performance this new software allowed
the animators to go from doing about
three seconds a week to north of seven
or eight for the fastest from an
efficiency standpoint it was incredible
and just what you could see evolving in
the moment was so helpful and just kind
of continuing to discover the characters
and why was 3d important for this to I
think it does there's a lot of when when
you're traveling between planets and all
that it makes sense but was that was
that something you felt very strongly
about you guys you know it's uh I the
last picture I director was over the
hedge which was in a moment before the
technology of 3d became you know really
powerful and I loved the opportunity for
3d because I do think it's immersive to
me 3d for the visual is like surround
sound for them for music and sound
effects if you're paying attention to it
it might be broken but it can be a very
immersive experience and luckily for us
bubbles and flying cars with things that
don't have contact with the edge of the
screen there particularly delightful in
3d I think we were even surprised when
we saw it we were like wow it's really
cool